y'a aucun moyen qu'on te sortent de
cette situation sans que tu passes par
la case prison
j'ai un plateau
[Musique]
je récupère ce qui est à nous je le
revends reliant disparaît on ne verra
plus jamais d'impôts m
on
peut laisser un bébé dans un hôpital
sans qu'on nous pose des questions c'est
la loi
de la lui rendre c'est clair
est-ce que tu as une idée du temps tu
passes en prison pour un enlèvement je
n'ai pas enlevé et du tout seul
je voudrais voir dans mon bureau
toi tu resteras loin de fléchir et tout
ça je te le promets
je qu'elle soit en bâtonnets et qu'ils
soient ou non
tu sais elle me sourit
mais merde
[Musique]
t'as pas besoin de venir
et je les mots si je sais
[Musique]